friday edition of pftpm wrapping up the
first of three weeks that pft live is on
hiatus and the big news on this day
before the fourth of july perfect time
to make a significant news dump although
i don't think it was strategically
selected this is more of a reaction
to pressure that has been placed on the
washington franchise by a couple of its
major sponsors fedex and nike bottom
line is the washington team announced
today that it's undergoing a thorough
review of its name here's the
full statement in light of recent events
around our country and feedback from our
community the washington franchise is
announcing that the team will undergo a
thorough review of the team's name this
review formalizes the initial
discussions the team has been having
with the league in recent weeks so
that's the first piece of news in the
statement that the league and the team
have been
talking about this
for a while for several weeks as
external forces have been pressuring the
team to change the name the league has
been working behind the scenes without
calling out daniel snyder publicly
working behind the scenes to try to get
him to change the name here's
schneider's statement this process
allows the team to take into account not
only the proud tradition and history of
the franchise but also input from our
alumni the organization sponsors the
national football league and the local
community it is proud to represent on
and off the field well we already know
what the sponsors think fedex said
yesterday changed the name nike didn't
say anything they just removed the team
entirely from the nike website expunged
the team like they never existed
pepsi came out today after the team
issued a statement said yes we'd also
like you to change the name so three
major sponsors targeted by 87 investment
firms have all now said or
acted in a way that makes their feelings
clear change the name the nfl clearly
wants the name to be changed the nfl
would have been working behind the
scenes with
daniel schneider to come up with a
strategy for keeping the name so
what the alumni thinks and i don't know
how much of a voice the alumni should
really have in this the organization i
assume means the players and the coaches
and others who now can speak more freely
internally because they don't feel that
financial pressure to say yeah sure boss
the name that you have said will never
change is fine with me
and then uh the local community they'll
get feedback from them as well but
here's the bottom line
you can't pull the pin on this grenade
and put it back in you can't say we are
engaging in a thorough review of the
name and then say at the end of the
review we've decided to keep the name
that would make it a million times worse
if you double down
after coming out with this grand
flourish and saying we are going to
consider
changing the name we're going to review
the name who's going to come out in
favor of the name of any of these
stakeholders who's going to do it in a
loud enough and persuasive enough voice
that gets the sponsors to stand down
that gets the league to stand down that
gets the media that has been pushing
this in some cases for years to stand
down that gets fans who look at it and
say what's the big deal to get them to
stand down so
they're gonna have a pr issue because
there are plenty of fans who will be mad
the name is going to change
but look they have to choose one or the
other
and here's the thing
once you go down the road of pissing off
the fans they're going to be mad because
you've said
you're engaging in a thorough review of
the name
once they're pissed off they're not
going to get unpissed off if you decide
to keep the name they're still going to
be pissed off that you put them through
this period where they thought the name
was going to change and then you're
going to piss off everyone else who
thought the name was changing bottom
line is
they have passed the point of no return
they have crossed the rubicon it is over
it is done
barring something miraculous
at this point
that name is changing
ron rivera the coach of the team said in
a statement
this issue is of personal importance to
me and i look forward to working closely
with dan snyder to make sure we continue
the mission of honoring and supportive
native americans and our military
honoring and supporting native americans
and our military now
when i read that i had the same reaction
plenty of other people do what the hell
is the military have to do with this
what's the military have to do with it
and my guess is my guess is
that maybe the next name
will in some way be tied to the military
now
it also sounds like they're going to try
to find a way to honor and support
native americans
and maybe also support and honor the
military
and you know that's not a that's not a
big needle to thread
if that's what they're thinking about
doing the bottom line is if the team is
still going to incorporate any native
american elements in its
logos its name
anything
you better be sure that the native
american community is on board and the
first organization to go to is the
national congress of american indians
that has been the group it is the
largest representative group of native
americans in america and that group has
been hammering for years
for a change to the name you don't want
them to pivot
from one name they don't like to another
name it's entirely possible at this
point the native american position will
be we don't want to have anything to do
with your team none nothing went no
we're done we're out we don't want to be
your mascot either with a name that
isn't a slur or the name that is a slur
so that
i think is something that will be part
of this review
see it can't just be
we're reviewing whether or not to keep
the name part of this review is what's
the new name going to be not that they
would say we don't like any of the other
names we're going to stick with the one
that's a dictionary defined slur but i
think this is all happening in the same
blender
the name's gone the name's done
the question is what will the new name
be the question is how quickly can they
incorporate the new name and is there a
way
to keep
the current uniform
to keep the current logo
and change the name
because when do you change the name
do you announce that after this season
the name is changing so we're just gonna
have one more year with a name that we
have decided
is problematic
is a dictionary defined racist slur
should not be the name of the team but
you know we're kind of ready to go for
this season we'd
be kind of inconvenient
to print up a bunch of jerseys also
remember one thing the nfl is always
very concerned about the inventory of
unsold jerseys although although
here's the first parallel that comes to
mind
anytime
there is a development in politics or
news that creates a perceived threat
to gun rights in any way
there's a run
on guns and ammunition
i suspect
that the people out there who will react
negatively to the news that washington
is considering changing its name will go
out and buy up everything they can find
that has the current name and logo on it
and all that stuff's going to be gone
it's going to solve the problem because
you're gonna have people
right or wrong
for the next 50 years who are wearing
gear
that bears the logo and the name of the
team as it's currently constituted two
games two tailgates out in public
not gonna be anything we can do about it
right
even as nascar tries to distance himself
from the confederate flag as mississippi
takes that piece of the confederate flag
out of its own flag
just go out for a drive especially this
weekend
i know where i live
i'll see at least one or two maybe three
trucks i'm gonna put the over under two
and a half trucks with
an american flag and a confederate flag
on each side of the bumper
i i guarantee it
so
that same dynamic is going to apply here
you're going to have people who proudly
wear
the
gear of the team as it's currently named
refuse to call it anything but it's
current name and that's why
here is break from the native american
context altogether
to make it harder
to make it not be wink nod you know what
we really are we've changed the name but
our fans know who we are they're not
going to sing hail to the something else
and we can't stop them from doing
so
the best way to do it is i think just
reset completely and find a name that
has nothing to do with the native
american community
especially if that's what they want
that's the first question
what
does the native american community want
do they want a name
that is specifically selected to honor
them that isn't a slur or do they want
out
and
if i were them at this point because it
took so long to get here i just want out
especially because
be concerned that if there still is a
native american component to the
official name you're going to have
thousands of fans who continue to use
the former name
and there's enough of a connection
to the new name
to make it sensible to do that
it's better to just go
in a completely different direction so
it looks goofy it's conspicuous it's
weird that you continue to cling to the
name that has been ditched by the
franchise
no timetable was given on how long this
review is going to take but i do think
the end result will be a new name and
we'll see what the new name is and look
i always say
wisdom often never comes at all it's
better that it show up late
and
hey
it is refreshing that daniel snyder
seems to realize the name is untenable
but at the same time
it really shouldn't have taken this long
it shouldn't have come to this
especially in this historic moment that
we are in the middle of
leading from behind not leading from the
front of the pack
and
daniel snyder's intransigence even
though the dam finally broke once big
money got involved once fedex got
involved and one of dan snyder's
partners
one of the guys that owns a chunk of the
team fred smith the founder of fedex
once that happens
you've got it you've got to cry uncle
but the cry of uncle should have come
long ago it's good that it's happening
it would have been better if it would
have happened a long time ago and it
would have been ideal now look i still
think it should have been changed at
least seven years ago if not earlier but
in this moment that we're in now
that's lasted for more than a month
it shouldn't have taken until july third
for something that happened
on memorial day
the murder of george floyd it shouldn't
have taken it until the day before the
fourth of july
for that light to go off in daniel
snyder's brain telling him it's time to
change the name but again
it look
the clock kept ticking more and more
loudly and the clock has reached all
caps never because that's what he said
in 2013 you can put it in caps never
really changed the name
and it's got to be very difficult for a
billionaire who is used to getting his
way all the time on anything and
everything to turn around and say okay i
yield and now he's yielding unless he
doubles down and makes it a million
times worse which i guess at this point
it's impossible to completely rule out
but i doubt i doubt
highly that we're gonna have anything
other than a new name to the team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports